[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce soir le coût réel des aliments qui
grimpa d'épicerie andréanne les
fabricants multiplient les stratégies
pour camoufler des hausses de prix ils
essaient de camoufler les hausses de
prix mais les consommateurs sont pas
dupes de toute façon on a chaque mois
des chiffres de statistique canada qui
nous montre effectivement que les prix
sont en hausse pour le mois de juillet
sur un an la hausse des prix des
aliments au restaurant c'était 3,1 pour
cent et à l'épicerie 1% en moyenne
certains produits coûtent moins cher
d'autres beaucoup plus cher on a des
chiffres pour le deuxième prix mais ça
veut dire quelques mois seulement voyez
les os pour certains produits la côte de
porc presque 68 pour cent soixante deux
pour cent d'augmentation poulet entier
15,7 pour cent les carottes 14 et demi
pour cent le fromage presque 7% des
pommes de terre les prix en hausse de 6%
des hausses de prix comme celle là
évidemment gerald vous le verrez pas
comme ça tel quel à l'épicerie ça ferait
fuir les consommateurs alors les
fournisseurs les fabricants de produits
alimentaires vont effectivement se
tourner vers une technique marketing
qu'on appelle la régulation c'est
simplement la contraction du mot
réduction et inflation ça veut dire
simplement des emballages plus petits
moins produit pour le même prix pour
pour qu'on se rende compte que ça monte
félidés faire de vous des exemples nous
donne on en a plusieurs qui ont été
compilées entre autres par le professeur
sylvain charlebois l'université
dalhousie on va prendre l'exemple d'un
sac de croustilles lay's le poids de ce
sac de croustilles là est passé de 180
grammes à 165 grammes on vous le vend au
même prix mais vous avez 28 3% -2 cost
et dans un sac les deux sacs de courses
pour protéger l'acoustique mais
effectivement les tranches de fromage
things de kraft le poids est passé de
450 grammes à 410 grammes pour un paquet
vous avez 22 tranche au lieu de 24 donc
une diminution de presque 9% et on a
plusieurs autres exemples comme ça
prenez par exemple dont les biscuits
oreo vous avez à peu près 11 % moins de
18 ans d'une voix de la pizza delissio
est presque 12% plus petit pour le même
prix le jus d'orange tropicana 12% moins
de volume la bouteille et la même forme
mais la bulle de plastique sous le
contenant est plus grosse avait moins de
jus et dans les emballages de barres
tendres coup et que vous avez cinq bars
au lieu de six évidemment c'est choquant
pour le consommateur mais il faut
comparer le prix par gramme ou par
volume c'est ce qui nous aide à savoir
si on a un bon rapport qualité-prix
d'accord merci beaucoup souvent pris
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i cirdi